pendant les premiers jours de la guerre
du golfe l'irak tirent des missiles sur
l'arabie saoudite et israël
si les alliés n'ont pas trop de
difficultés à éliminer l'aviation
irakienne
le repérage des rampes et le lancement
mobile de ces missiles était une tâche
bien plus délicate
pourtant il est essentiel de les
détruire israël répliqué à cette attaque
la guerre risquerait de s'étendre à tout
le proche orient et même au delà les ss
c'est à dire les unités d'élite de
l'armée anglaise furent appelés à
intervenir
le sergent andy mcnab était à la tête
d'un commando de huit hommes infiltrés
derrière les lignes ennemies trois
furent tués et quatre autres faits
prisonniers
un dernier réussit à regagner sa base
sains et saufs
l'histoire de ce commando illustre bien
l'esprit des sas
au niveau opérationnel il hérite
toujours de mission impossible frappant
l'ennemi là où il s'y attend le moins
employant des stratégies et les
tactiques très éloigné de l'orthodoxie
militaire ceci est leur histoire
non
comme la plupart des autres puissances
militaires la grande bretagne dispose
d'unités mobiles spécialisés dans les
interventions outre mer au cours des
vingt dernières années elles ont été
déployés aux malouines au proche-orient
en bosnie est dans la province serbe du
kosovo
les créations de force d'intervention
spéciale résulte des nouvelles
conditions dans lesquelles se déroule le
conflit avec la sophistication des
stratégies et des armements
le temps des gros bataillons a pris fin
les professionnels remplacent les
conscrits les hommes sont moins nombreux
mais mieux formés aux conditions
spécifiques de la guerre moderne
mais là encore certaines opérations sont
trop délicatement des troupes
conventionnelles
il faut faire appel à des spécialistes
en angleterre ce sont les sas les
special air service qui comme leur nom
l'indiqué sont des unités de
parachutistes
c'est un simple lieutenant david
sterling qui contre l'avis de ses
hiérarchies réussit à imposer pendant la
dernière guerre mondiale
l'idée de petits commandos hyper
spécialisés chargés d'opérer derrière
les lignes allemandes
si la mission était claire personne ne
savait vraiment quel résultat
opérationnel on pouvait espérer en
allant derrière la ligne de front
espionner sa beauté les lignes de romell
les sas pourrait-il coupé de tout
approvisionnement survivre dures
conditions du désert et comment
pourrait-il faire face à la réaction de
la nuit
faute d'expérience préalable il fallut
tout improvisé et l'entraînement était
des plus réduits dans cette guerre du
désert
le front était extrêmement mobile et le
temps manquait pour mettre au point et
peaufiner des exercices à l'entraînement
plusieurs hommes trouvèrent la mort en
opération aussi mais ce qui survivaient
tirer vite les leçons de leur échec
sterling avait la conviction que la
motivation alliée à des dons innés et à
une expérience pratique acquise sur le
terrain permettait de surmonter tous les
obstacles
après quelques débuts hasardeuse les
résultats furent au rendez vous du point
de vue opérationnel
cette unité d'une quarantaine d'hommes
obtenez des résultats dignes d'une
division
face à ces attaques surprises
les allemands avaient bien du mal à
trouver une réplique ne sachant jamais
où ils frapperaient la fois suivante
remet elle était obligée d'affecter un
nombre sans cesse croissant de soldats à
la surveillance des dépôts de matériel
de munitions ou des sens
8 les sas sur la réputation d'être des
troupes différentes et si le
haut-commandement nez mais toujours pas
ses soldats à 2000 francs tireurs force
est de reconnaître qu'ils étaient
efficaces
tandis que les ss se forger une
réputation d'autres unités de commandos
virent le jour dans d'autres armes les
sps par exemple qui dépendait de la
marine les effectué de nombreuses
missions de sabotage aux côtés de la
résistance dans la france occupée
et la paix venue des ss furent
démantelées tous les commandos verser
dans les royal marines c'est-à-dire
l'infanterie de marine traditionnelle
les opérations de maintien de l'ordre en
malaisie leur permis de renaître en
avait besoin d'eux pour faire face un
nouveau type d'opération militaire la
guérilla au début les stratèges anglais
penser qu'il suffirait de répliquer par
des opérations de police la police était
impuissante et quand ils firent appel à
des unités classiques avec un armement
lourd
ce fut pour constater qu'elle aussi
était inefficace
seuls des commandos léger autonome et
super entraîné et est adapté à cette
nouvelle forme de conflit de nos jours
les sas sont attachés à l'armée
régulière
le 22e régiment de slc deux unités de
réserve territoriales sont basés à
hereford près du pays de galles le 23e
régiment et dans le nord de l'angleterre
est le 21e à londres en tout ils ne sont
guère plus de 400 les sbs moins
nombreuse sans leurs homologues de la
marine ils sont basés près de poule sur
la côte sud pour des raisons pratiques
les ss et les sbs ont été placés sous un
commandement unique bien évidemment ils
dépendent du ministère des armées
mais leur utilisation tactique échappe à
la chaîne de commandement régulière le
rôle opérationnel est vaste il va de la
délivrance d'otages à des missions de
reconnaissance en profondeur si l'emploi
des ss au proche orient dans les
malouines et dans les balkans n'a donné
lieu à aucune critique
il n'en va pas de même pour leurs
interventions de leicester qui ont
suscité de vives controverses contraint
de se livrer à des missions de basse
police les ss aurait eu recours à des
méthodes d'interrogatoire musclées
absolument inadmissible
dans les opérations anti terroristes les
sas entre en revanche remporté des
succès remarquables notamment en 1981
lors d'une prise d'otages à l'ambassade
d'iran à londres
parfaitement entraînés et équipés les
sas ont mené l'assaut de façon
exemplaire
dès que l'ordre a été donné les
terroristes ont été abattus sans pouvoir
opposer la moindre résistance et si l'un
d'eux a reçu 82 balles dans le corps
il est à noter qu aucun otage n'a été
blessé
remarquablement synchronisée l' attaque
dévastatrice n'a duré que quelques
minutes
si les sas ne sont décidément pas un
soldat comme les autres la plupart des
hommes qui les composent embrasse la
carrière militaire sans avoir vraiment
l'intention de rejoindre ses commandos
en fait le recrutement se fait parmi des
engagés ordinaire le premier critère de
sélection c'est la capacité de réagir
correctement face à une situation
compliquée et inattendue dans les
commandos on ne cherche pas des rambo
mais des hommes capables d'analyser très
vite la situation et de réagir comme il
convient john smit fait partie du
commando qui a donné l'assaut contre
l'ambassade d'iran et libérer les otages
il nous explique encore caméra comment
il convient d'agir pour exterminer les
terroristes
on combat les hommes traversent deux
zones la zone critique et la zone à
portée de ravitaillement dans la zone
critique les hommes ne maîtrise pas les
paramètres extérieurs ils sont dos au
mur
ceci leur permet de cette expression sas
prod ne sont pas seulement des hommes
armés vêtus de treillis campagne et
encagoulés qui charge sont décrits
frayant les hurlements c'est d'un mode
d'attaqué qui remonte à l'époque des
baïonnettes et vise à distraire
l'adversaire pour john smith les
techniques mises au point par les ss
pour faire face à des situations
critiques tels que les prises d'otages
leur donne davantage sur la
quasi-totalité de leurs adversaires vous
avez un avantage absolu parce que vous
savez ce que vous allez voir quand vous
allez le faire
comment vous allez le faire et vous
n'êtes pas seuls la technique que
j'enseigne se résume en trois mois
surprise agressivité et rapidité et de
ses paramètres conditionne le troisième
si vous avez un bon élément de surprise
si vous êtes rapide
autre action sera automatiquement
agressif vous êtes agressif et rapide
vous obtiendrez toujours un effet de
surprise
enfin si vous avez la surprise et
l'agressivité vous serez automatiquement
rapide
ainsi donc ces trois éléments qui vous
donne le troisième haut mais dès
l'instant où vous n'avez qu'un seul de
ces éléments dénis bonneau le mieux
par exemple si vous êtes trop ou pas
assez rapide 30 points pas assez vous
allez passer à côté de l'élément sur
l'élément le plus difficile à maîtriser
c'est sans doute la vitesse d'exécution
faut impérativement garder le rythme
smith estime que la puissance de feu
bien qu'importantes ne saurait remplacer
la maîtrise de soi
pour lui le succès dépend d'une absolue
maîtrise de ces réactions physiques et
émotionnels les armes les plus
perfectionnés ne remplace pas le
sang-froid et la volonté de vaincre et
cette règle est aussi valable dans les
opérations de police que sur un champ de
bataille classique
ces exercices intensifs ont pour but
d'acquérir des réflexes des automatismes
parfois une fraction de seconde fait la
différence entre la vie et la mort et on
n'a pas le temps de réfléchir pour
l'intervention
l'ambassade d'iran l'entraînement
spécifique a duré plus longtemps que
d'habitude
et pendant que les négociations se
poursuivaient l'intervention a été
minutieusement programme est en fait en
ce qui concerne la phase opérationnelle
proprement dite la seule différence par
rapport à l'entraînement c'est qu'on
avait des cibles vivantes
voici quelques images d'une séance
d'entraînement sur la base des réformes
une des règles d'or c'est que les sas ne
sont pas super mal leurs compétences
opérationnelles sont le fruit d'une
rigoureuse préparation ni plus ni moins
l'idéal dss n'est pas de mourir pour
leur cause mais que l'ennemi meurent
pour la sienne ce moment où l'on entre
en action on déconnecte complètement
point de vue avant de passer à l'attaqué
la réflexion et même le doute sont
encouragées quand il s'agit de finaliser
c'est autre chose
cela ne veut pas dire que vous cessez de
penser non mais vous fonctionnez un
autre niveau
en principe vous savez ce qui va se
passer mais devait être prêt à toute
éventualité
vous devez être alerte vigilant surtout
ne pas oublier que c'est votre vie qui
est en jeu sas ne sont pas des
suicidaires ils tiennent à leur peau que
le feu vert est donné
le ss est totalement on a l'esprit
tellement concentré qu'il a l'impression
que les temps s'est ralenti il faut
analyser tous les éléments
d'informations qu'ils recueillent ce
qu'ils voient ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils
entendent les traités en conséquence et
agir en une fraction de seconde un
frémissement de la main un regard à
peine appuyé trahissent le danger on
communique par la parole mais participe
conventionnelle et par le langage du
corps si la discipline collective est
importante
la force principale des ss résulte des
qualités propres à chaque individu
quel que soit le type de mission
l'efficacité des aides
pourquoi font-ils des choses que les
autres ne peuvent pas faire pourquoi
russie style on sent presque tout sera
entrepris de mon avis le mythe des sas
repose d'abord sur l'expérience de
chaque individu
les soldats de ces régiments sont
matures 3 l'âge moyen est de 27 28 ans
il n'y a pas de bleus il n'y a pas de
réaction passé seulement quelques
instants dans la plupart des membres des
ss et monte au minimum le grade de
caporal ou sergent en d'autres termes
sont déjà une expérience du commandement
et des prises de responsabilités mais
s'ils ont été promus c'est grâce aux
compétences et au sens de vue sciatique
qu'ils ont manifesté sur le terrain et
puis la sélection est très dure il ne
suffit pas de postuler pour être à neige
en conséquence les membres des sas sont
des gens qui veulent vraiment aller plus
loin dans leur métier que le soldat - co
ce sont tous des hommes et 1 messieurs
c'est là l'essentiel pour battre
il ne s'agit pas d'une bande de glace
turbulent ils étaient brûlés et de type
équilibrée des professionnels motivés
qui savent ce qu'ils veulent
les ssd hommes viennent de tous les
horizons dans la section le sergent
avait servi provenaient de la l'autre
des services de renseignement le
troisième service technique de
l'armement polyvalence permet de faire
face à toutes les situations en
opération si on récupère un canot partie
nous aura la charge et voilà donc et si
ça tombe en panne et techniciens saura
le réparer sort à désamorcer une mine
improvisée un pays si vous avez une
bande de gaza s'ils ont tous une
formation différente et chacun peut
apporter sa contribution le moment venu
avec de telles sommes on peut faire face
à un tas de situations imprévues ou
l'imprévu justement on essaie de le
réduire au maximum chaque comme on part
du principe que si ça peut mal tourner
ça tournera mal et comme il a de
l'expérience et fait tout ce qu'il peut
pour éliminer les sites mais tout le
monde s'attend à devoir improviser à un
moment ou un autre dans les unités de ss
il n'y a pas de problème de leadership
jacob gelé une expérience du
commandement c'est aussi bien recevoir
des ordres que d'en donner et ses ordres
peuvent les amener à intervenir
n'importe où et sans préavis
chaque mission est différente le célèbre
kit de combat dss est un mythe inspiré
par les james bond
en réalité chaque homme choisit son
matériel en fonction de sa mission et
parce que ces missions sont très
diverses les hommes doivent être
capables de se servir d'un armement très
variés
le fusil mitrailleur mp5 fait partie de
leur panoplie standard phenom
polyvalente précise et rapide
la procédure de tir et codifié chez les
sas on n'arrose pas tout ce qui bouge
comme dans le film on tire quelques
balles ont reperdu possible et on assume
contrat fall le niveau d arme de poing
ils utilisent parfois des automatique
mais le bon vieux revolver qu'on ne s'en
est jamais et davantage apprécié souvent
nés sas se retrouvent dans des
situations où le port d'armes est
strictement interdite
cela ne signifie pas pour autant qu'ils
sont incapables de se défendre ils sont
en effet formés au combat à mains nues
ou presque
l'un de leur truc préféré c'est ce petit
bâton plots en plastique compact c'est
facile à dissimuler et même si on le
repère il semble bien innocent est
utilisée selon les règles il peut se
révéler très efficace
un ancien instructeur des forces
spéciales nous explique comment les ss
interviennent quand ils ont l'ordre de
disperser une foule de manifestants
face à une foule qui n'est pas agressive
il convient d'utiliser une technique
d'arrestation douzy aussi peu offensive
que possible l'objectif est de nous
faire obéir en infligeant un minimum de
douleur juste ce qu'il faut pour que les
gens fassent ce que nous leur demandons
de faire
prenons l'exemple d'un manifestant qui
se cramponne à une barrière et qui
refuse d'obtempérer
désolé monsieur vous devez circuler
alors circulé dans ce cas nous disposons
de deux techniques avec la main ouverte
en exerçant une pression sur l'épaule
comme ça puis ensuite les collègues se
chargent de l'embarqué voici maintenant
la même situation mais avec usage du
petit bâton les manifestants refusent
toujours d'obtempérer
je m'approche même je place le bâton sur
le poignet je tire une très légère
torsion sur le bras voilà ce sont les
procédures d'arrestation des plus douce
face à quelqu'un qui n'oppose que la
force d'inertie
il n'y a pas de problème la procédure
suivante un peu plus dur s'applique aux
manifestants qui essaient de résister on
s'agrippe à dans ce cas aussi de
disposer de deux options l'une à mains
nues l'autre à l'aide du petit bac vous
avancez vers la personne agressive votre
réaction immédiate doit être de pivoter
d'un quart de tour et de dégager
si la prise de cendres à gauche avec
votre main droite vous saisissez
fermement sur son poignet gauche et vous
dégagez en reculant et en exerçant une
torsion sur le bras poursuivez le
mouvement jusqu'à ce que l'homme soit à
terre relâchez la torsion et rabat et
l'avant-bras de la personne interpellée
sur sa poitrine
dans le même temps bloqué cette nouvelle
clé en passant votre bras gauche par
l'intérieur même scénario mais avec le
bâton cette fois nous allons l'utiliser
pour exercer une pression qui va
permettre de plier le poignet et de
réaliser une clé est bien plus efficace
car la pression sur le poignet sera plus
forte
allez il faut partir
même mouvement le bâton de part et
d'autre des poignets ils lâchent la
prise saisissez le pouce retourné la
main appliquer une pression pour plier
le bras et accompagner le de ses
méthodes il faut bien dire ont trouvé
leurs limites dans le conflit en ulster
certains irlandais récalcitrants était
tout aussi expert en bagarre de rue et
quelques sms se sont retrouvés à
l'hôpital
voyons maintenant comment ils procèdent
à l'arrestation d'un homme dans sa
voiture nous allons à présent utiliser
ce petit bâton pour extraire quelqu'un
d'une voiture le scénario c'est que la
voiture est arrêtée et que le conducteur
refuse de sortir la vitre latérale peut
être fermée et dans ce cas il y a lieu
de la briser avec le bâtonnat mais pour
cet exercice on suppose qu'elle est
ouverte
le problème quand on brise la vitre
c'est que le conducteur s'éloigne de
vous et qu'il faut plonger à l'intérieur
de la voiture pour s'en saisir
donc nous allons le tirer hors de la
voiture avec la vitre latérale ouvert
étant entendu que la porte est
verrouillée
sorti de la voiture alors on ne bougeait
plus debout contre la voiture ne
bougeait plus
encore une fois ses talents particuliers
ont été mis à rude épreuve dans le
conflit en ulster
il suppose une certaine collaboration de
la part de la victime et les gens de
l'ira ne se laissait pas maîtriser aussi
facilement
d'ailleurs une vive polémique a éclaté
en angleterre et jusqu'au parlement
certains ont fait valoir que les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre ne
sont pas de la compétence des troupes
d'élite leur rôle devrait se limiter à
un appui opérationnel tactique de
l'armée régulière
les sbs unité d'élite rattachée à la
marine opère dans un cadre plus
restreint
ils sont exclusivement engagé dans des
missions de patrouille non seulement
dans les montagnes de l'arctique comme à
l'origine
mais sous tous les climats du monde au
cours des deux dernières années
l'entraînement a davantage porté sur un
rôle opérationnel
les sbs désormais prêt pour des missions
de reconnaissance et d'appui au commando
à filtrer en territoire hostile
nous avons développé la formation aux
missions de renseignement alors que dans
le passé
l'accent était mis sur le combat
rapproché mes hommes travaillent par
demi section de six hommes quand le
commander par un sergent deux caporaux
et trois marines
tous sont des spécialistes en opération
de reconnaissance mais en plus ce qu ils
ont chacun une autre compétence
communication ou du moins ce qu'ont
affirmé en camouflage etc
chacun doit également être capable de
prendre immédiatement le commandement de
son unité
cette polyvalence leur donne une grande
autonomie sont de véritables commandos
libre vous capable de prendre des
initiatives sur le terrain et
d'accomplir leur mission sans être
directement sous le contrôle du
commandement en action ils ne sont pas
censés faire un rapport et attendre les
hommes
là on est la principale différence avec
les autres unités de commandos pratiques
qui sont directement commande est
irresponsable de vente elle leur mission
bien définie au départ peu évolué une
fois sur le terrain
glam les informations qu'il peut glaner
et agit en fonction de ce qu'il a trouvé
généralement les commandos sas et sbs à
30 40
et même 50 km de leur base ils ne sont
que rarement censée engager le combat
leur rôle est de passer inaperçu et de
préparer le terrain pour des missions
offensives le d'autre part seront
chargés d'exécuter dans l'avenir
c'est très facile de commander une telle
unité en accion car chaque homme est
très motivé ses compétences
professionnelles sont au top niveau
il est fier de servir et il aime son
travail une fois qu'un homme a reçu un
travail à faire il le fera dans la
plupart des cas ils sont que moi mais
pour mon supérieur hiérarchique
voyons dans l'obligation de leur donner
perpétuellement d une fois qu'ils ont
leurs ambitions galan ii ils s'envolent
accompli ces exercices de survie sont
caractéristiques de l'entraînement que
reçoivent les sbs il ne s'agit pas
d'attaquer mais de survivre d'accomplir
sa mission sans se faire repérer dans le
cadre de cet exercice sur une île au
large de l'ecosse en plein hiver ils
sont largués en pleine nature avec un
équipement minimum et ils doivent vivre
sur le pays pendant toute une semaine
avant de partir on nous a remis cette ré
lire à 9,3 une portion de ragoût et ont
été largués vers sept heures du soir il
faisait nuit
il y avait du vent il pleuvait pour
commencer on s'est éloigné de la grande
route qui est à peu près 1 500 m d'ici
puis on s'est remis à la recherche d'un
abri pour la nuit
on a fini par trouver une maison en
ruine on y lit a élu domicile le
lendemain matin on s'est levés vers 7
heures et on a cherché quelque chose de
mieux les risques de se faire repérer
sur est moins grand on a trouvé quelques
débris de loin cela ressemblait
décharges sauvages
c'est là que nous avons déménagé cet
abri est certes sommaire mais suffisant
pour protéger les hommes du vent glacial
et de la pluie
cela fait les sbs se met à la recherche
de tout objet pouvant être utiles pour
la suite des opérations
leur kit de survie rangé dans une huile
boîte à tabac est réduit au strict
minimum
mais dans ces conditions extrêmes il
peut faire la différence entre la vie et
la mort des hameçons on emporte entre 10
et 20 un bas de ligne testé environ 10
kilos
quelques plombs pour maintenir l'hameçon
dans le fond on a aussi une bougie qu'on
peut laisser allumées afin d'économiser
les allumettes un stick de camouflage
est aussi nécessaire à couture des
préservatifs n'emporte 2 3 il peut
servir à stocker l'eau ici on a trouvé
un peu partout des vieilles casseroles
et de quoi allumer du feu
il ya aussi des allumettes et un bloc de
paraffine qui permet d'entretenir un feu
en milieu humide
je trouvais aussi des tablettes pour
purifier l'eau bien sûr et quelques
carrés de bouillon cube pour lui donner
un peu de goût et là vous voyez sur le
couvercle vous avez des des hameçons de
secours il ya aussi un élément avec
lequel on peut bricoler une boussole
s'il ya lieu
et pour finir on trouve aussi un jeu
d'aiguillés à coudre la recherche de
nourriture est la priorité numéro 2
numéro 2
car en meurt beaucoup plus vite de froid
que de faim ici la ressource alimentaire
la plus accessible est constitué par les
lièvres avec le bout de la ligne destiné
à la pêche
les hommes ont improvisé à coller et le
résultat est encourageant
l'animal est dépassé dans les règles et
confiée aux cuistots
dans le groupe il y a toujours un homme
capable d'identifier les plantes
comestibles
il doit faire preuve de vigilance car la
moindre erreur peut rendre malade tout
le monde
si l'on fait bouillir des feuilles dans
l'eau c'est tout simplement parce que le
corps et retient beaucoup plus
facilement un liquide contenant une
licence de plantes
ces compétences sont aussi importantes
que le maniement d'armes ou le close
combat et chaque soldat apprend ici à
déjouer des pièges qu'ils ne
soupçonnaient pas tout le monde a été
surpris par les effets de la
déshydratation et du manque de
nourriture dite normale extrêmement
épuisant soudain une petite marche
jusqu'au locke aperçoit juste la barre
vous laisse totalement vidée cela fait
deux kilomètres aller retour
mais l'expédition qui paraît très facile
se révèle bien plus important qu'on ne
l'aurait imaginé
c'est effectivement quelque chose de
beaucoup plus dur ce qu'on a appris deux
plus importants jusqu'ici c'est que si
tout va mal si on est séparé de notre
unité survivent grâce à notre petite
boîte ça la fin de cet exercice
chacun des participants se verra confier
la responsabilité d'un commando composé
d'autres sans tom cecos et il devra
savoir ce qu'il fait s'il est perdu d
économiser son énergie gérer ses efforts
est absolument vital en milieu hostile
si pour aller pêcher un poisson
dépensent plus de calories qu'en
contient un poisson il faut tir danser
la mission principale de ces hommes est
de réunir des renseignements et non
d'engager le combat se sont au sens
strict du terme des éclaireurs c'est à
dire les yeux et les oreilles du corps
auquel ils sont rattachés
les sas parachutistes aujourd'hui
intégrés dans la force de réaction
rapide européenne peuvent être envoyés
en opération du jour l'an
et leur mission est toujours là mère
ouvrir la voie pour le reste des trous
ce sont des spécialistes du saut à très
haute altitude avec ouverture du
parachute à très basse altitude
il leur arrive de s'élancer le plus de
10000 mètres ce qui nécessite l'usagé
d'un masque à oxygène pour ne pas perdre
conscience
les largages à de telles altitudes sont
tactiquement utile en premier lieu les
hommes disposent de plusieurs minutes de
chute libre pour se rapprocher de leurs
cibles
en d'autres termes on peut les larguer à
une certaine distance de l'objective ce
qui favorise la surprise d'autre part à
haute altitude l'image radar de l'avion
transporteurs peuvent facilement se
confondre avec celle d'autres appareils
d'attac ce qui réduit les risques
d'avoir un comité d'accueil qui attend
les paras à l'atterrissage au moment où
ils sont le plus vulnérables
l'équipement des ss varie en fonction
des missions au minimum ils ont par une
arme d'habitude un fusil mitrailleur
m-16 quelques munitions des rations de
survie une trousse médicale avec
antiseptique antibiotiques pansements et
morphine et une gourde d'eau mais
parfois il leur arrive d'être beaucoup
plus chargé
on cite l'exemple d'un sas qui lors de
la campagne des malouines était lesté
avec plus de 100 kg de matériel malgré
le prestige du m16
les sas sont considérés comme des unités
disposant d'un armement léger
en cas de confrontation avec des forces
conventionnelles ils ne peuvent pas
soutenir un combat prolongé ils doivent
se replier et se limiter à des
opérations de retardement ou de
harcèlement en économisant les munitions
en vérité leur force réside dans leur
capacité à passer inaperçue lors des
missions de reconnaissance
ils doivent avancer prudemment dans un
silence absolu et éviter tout ce qui
pourrait révéler leurs positions
la patrouille généralement composé de
quatre hommes doit faire preuve de la
plus extrême vigilance
l'ennemi surgir à tout moment et de
n'importe où chaque homme à tour de rôle
est chargé d'ouvrir le chemin tout en
restant sur leurs gardes
ses camarades peuvent relâcher un peu
leur tension voir s'allonger un moment
car il ne faut jamais présumer de ses
forces
l'homme de garde se place toujours à
quelques distances de ses collègues au
repos il est relié à eux par une ficelle
si l'ennemi est en vue aucune parole ne
sera échangée il lui suffira de tirer la
ficelle pour donner l alerte
ces hommes sont très conscients des
risques du métier
ils savent que leur vie peuvent dépendre
d'un bon réflexe d'un bon entraînement
lors de la guerre du golfe les en ont
fait l'expérience
en 1990 nation irakienne du koweït a
étonné le monde entier il faudra
plusieurs mois avant que les troupes
américaines françaises et britanniques
prise au dépourvu soit en mesure
d'attaquer saddam hussein la coalition
aline des forces impressionnante vaincu
dans les airs le dictateur irakien
relève la mise en bombardant israël avec
ses missiles scud l'inquiétude est
grande dans les chancelleries
si l'état hébreu riposte avec ses armes
nucléaires secrètes
elles n'ont de secret tu que le nom le
conflit risque fort de s'étendre à tout
le proche orient
dépêchés sur place de toute urgence les
missiles antimissiles patriot apporte un
réconfort moral mais se révèle que
moyennement efficace des consultations
fébrile réunissent les responsables
alliés
avec leurs bombes intelligentes et leurs
missiles close
ils peuvent sans aucun doute détruire
tous les objectifs qu'ils désirent
encore faut-il les repérer or malgré
leur réseau de satellites et d'avions de
reconnaissance ils n'y parviennent pas
de toute évidence les irakiens sont
passés maîtres dans l'art de dissimuler
les rampes de lancement mobile de leurs
scud
il ne reste donc qu'une solution confier
le repérage et éventuellement la
destruction de ces missiles à des
fantasmes des sas sont chargé de la
besogne
comme au temps de la guerre contre romel
ils vont devoir opérer encore dans le
désert
ils sont vrais entraîné comme il le faut
et dotés de l'équipement adéquat sergent
dans les ss à cette époque
andy mcnab diriger la patrouille bravo 2
0 sa mission repérer et si possible
détruire les missiles scud derrière les
lignes irakienne il nous décrit cette
opération d'habitude nous opérons par
patrouille de quatre
mais cette fois là où vous nous est
désigné un autre chef de patrouille
on a tous été appelés au rapport par
l'officier commandant l'escadron b il
nous a dit qu'on avait une mission et
nous allons remis un ordre d'opération
il s'agit d'un bref document qui définit
en gros la tâche à accomplir et donne
toutes les indications susceptibles de
fourmies d'être utile en cours
d'opération
cette fois là parce que nous risquions
d'être longtemps isolé il a été décidé
que deux patrouilles seraient fusionnés
ce temps là c'est à dire nous prévoyons
à 8
notre travail consistait d'abord a coupé
une ligne de communication téléphonique
entre bagdad et les équipes chargées de
lancer les missiles qui se trouvaient
dans le nord ouest de l'iran crétins
passe comme si on n'y parvenaient les
artilleurs ne serait plus gand et dans
quelles directions tirer leurs missiles
ce qui nous éviterait de devoir tenter
une attaque directe contre les rampes
car ce que l'on recherche c'est à
infliger le maximum de dommages avec un
effort minimum
ainsi donc notre première tâche était de
trouver cette ligne 2
téléphone qui suis plus ou moins la
route qui relie bagdad à la jordanie
si on n'y parvenait pas notre mission
était d'attaquer les scans trois
possibilités se présentait alors si
possible on devait utiliser nos moyens
de transmission pour indiquer
l'emplacement des rampes à l'aviation
qui effectuerez alors un raid de
destruction si cela se révélait
impossible on devait s'approcher
suffisamment des rampes de lancement et
détruire les missiles à la roquette anti
tanks et si ça ne marchait pas il y
avait lieu d'éliminer les soldats de
garde et de détruire les rampes de
lancement à la main ou avec de petites
charges explosives
en aucun cas il ne fallait détruire les
missiles dont les ogives pourrait
contenir des charges chimiques et
bactériologiques qui nous réduit tandis
que les opérations alliées se
poursuivent et par de puissantes
attaques aériennes prélude à l'assaut
terrestre et ss se préparer à intervenir
dans un environnement extrêmement
hostile le désert
le 22 janvier le sergent mcnabb et les
sept autres membres du commando embarque
dans un hélicoptère de combat qui
s'enfonce aussitôt dans l'espace aérien
ennemis nous avons pénétré en irak est
suivi la route prévue à un moment nous
avons été pris en chasse par ce qui
devait être un missile roland c'était
très effrayant
l'équipage de l'hélicoptère a su mériter
sa solde
in car on volait à une vitesse de 150
km/heure et à moins de 25 mètres au
dessus du sol savoure échapper au
missile
le chinook a dû reprendre de l'altitude
afin de pouvoir manoeuvrer
c'était vraiment très effrayant et nous
étions très heureuse quand il s'est posé
quand les portes se sont ouvertes quatre
hommes sont allés sécuriser le terrain
et couvrir tous les angles de tirs
tandis que les autres se charger de
débarquer le matériel pour cette
patrouille offensive à pied chaque homme
transportait environ 25 kg d'équipements
puis l'hélicoptère a décollé essaie
d'écrire une fausse quand nous avons
retiré notre premier site de lancement à
une dizaine de kilomètres à l'ouest du
pont d'atterrissage
à ce stade de l'opération nous ne
pouvions rien faire
on s'est donc mise à la recherche d'une
plante qui était destiné à constituer
notre point de ralliement
il se trouvait à environ 20 km du site
nous avons passé la nôtre première nuit
et au matin nous avons tenté de signaler
notre position est d'envoyer un rapport
mais malgré bien des efforts tout au
long de la journée
c'est nos communications sont restés
sans réponse et pourtant chaque membre
du commando ont été formés aux
techniques de transmission
le lendemain on a eu le même problème le
moindre contact possible
c'était embêtant mais une telle
éventualité était prévu vers 4h30 de
l'après midi on a entendu un troupeau de
chèvres qui passait pas très long mais
ce n'était pas un problème car on était
bien planté et on avait laissé aucune
trace qui puisse conduire à notre point
de ralliement fonctionne malheureusement
nous avions planté une mitrailleuse
jumelées de décès à environ 200 mètres
de nous au nord-ouest et le jeune berger
un gamin de 5 ou 6 ans les aperçus il a
ouvert des yeux gros comme des oeufs sur
le plat sexe il a compris ce qui se
passait et il s'est enfui en hurlant
sous nous étions opéré et il a fallu
brusquer le mouvement nous sommes donc
préparés à faire une sortie cela
consistait à boire autant d'eau que
possible car on savait qu avant d'entrer
au contact de l'ennemi
il nous faudrait pas recourir très vite
une assez grande distance sous le soleil
du désert
nous avons donc vu des litres et des
litres d'eau tout en ingurgitant des
tablettes de chocolat sous le pour que
le liquide qui nous tiennent au corps on
était en train de faire le plein quand
on a entendu un bruit de chenille dans
le lointain immédiatement chacun a pris
son poste de son bas et ces roquettes
antichars mais en fait il s'agissait
d'un bulldozer qui remontait la route en
direction de bagdad après son passage on
s'est mis en route la chine nous avons
abandonné beaucoup d'équipements sur
place on s'est contenté de notre
ceinture cartouchière de nos armées de
quelques provisions et médicaments bien
être sac à dos
au bout de quatre ou cinq cents mètres
nous avons aperçu les deux véhicules
légers blindés mais ce n'est que tous
rêvent de mitrailleuses à canal bourse
qui s'avançait vers nous l'infanterie
suivait dans un véhicule pas chez nous
avons ouvert les hostilités
non pas par la volonté d'attaquer mais
parce qu'il n'y avait rien d'autre à
faire qu'on a laissé tomber les
roquettes antichars
car à cette distance on avait peu de
chances de faire mouche et vul en toi
elle aurait représenté une entrave à
notre mobilité le désert irakien est
très plat mais il ya toujours moyen de
se mettre à couvert derrière un rocher
et derrière une anfractuosité du terrain
c'était une autre attaque a été
immédiate et d apporter sur les
fantassins afin de les abattre ou tout
au moins de contacts en empêcher leur
déploiement
le gros problème c'était les deux vlb
contre lesquels notre feu était
impuissant par chance infanterie ne les
a pas suivis
et tandis qu'il s'approchait un de nos
hommes a réussi à récupérer un lance
roquettes
en deux coups bien ajuster les allumer
le combat avait duré une quarantaine de
minutes
on a alors décidé de décrocher car les
soldats irakiens avaient la supériorité
numérique
on espérait qu'il en ferait autant mais
ils ne nous ont pas lâchés
en fait seule la tombée de la nuit nous
a sauvés car il avait appelé des
renforts
lesquels s'étaient joints à eux pour
nous canarder de tous côtés
heureusement il ne disposait pas de flou
après examen de la situation j'ai décidé
qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre solution que
de s'enfuir vers la frontière syrienne à
175 kilomètres de là tu as essayé de
passer en force
jusqu'à une base de lancement de ce code
n'aurait servi qu'à se faire tuer
inutilement de toute évidence s'il y
avait dans ce secteur c'est beaucoup
plus de troupes irakiennes qu'on nous
l'avait dit après la guerre en afrique
ils étaient plus de 3000
d'autre part cette densité de troupes
rand est impossible tout secours par
hélicoptère maintenant guide été alertés
les irakiens la batterie presque à coup
sûr s'il tentait de se poser c'est
pourquoi j'ai décidé de tenter notre
chance vers la syrie pour tromper le mot
suivant on a d'abord pris la direction
du sud de l'arabie saoudite dans
l'espoir qu'il établirait des barrages
sur ce tracé
nous avons abandonné nos lauriers car il
gênait nos manoeuvres lorsqu'on tentait
d'échapper aux tirs de loin notre
opérateur radio avait planqué un
émetteur dans un des tubes et il l'avait
laissé branché sur la fréquence sos
on nous avait dit que les avions awacs
assurer une couverture permanente de
l'espace aérien irakien et serait donc
comme mesure de capter ce signal et de
nous envoyer un appui aérien
cool en théorie ça marche très bien on
établit le contact et dans les 15
secondes qui fit une voix très posée
parce que féminine vous rappelle aux
cages et propose des solutions concrètes
pour vous venir en aide
ça c'est la théorie mais après coup on a
appris qu'on se trouvait hors de portée
des à ouakam leur zone de réception
s'arrêter à 300 km plus au sud
tandis que les scuds continuer de
s'abattre sur l'arabie saoudite et sur
israël mcnabb épouse de plus en plus de
difficultés pour poursuivre sa marche
vers la syrie madame a été blessé lors
de la fusillade un autre commence à
souffrir d'hypothermie
les nuits dans le désert sont glaciales
dans la confusion des combats
le commando a été séparée en deux
groupes trois hommes d'un côté quatre
autres de l'autre dont le sergent mcnabb
les deux groupes ont perdu le contact
malgré tout madame ne désespère pas des
mois et des mois d'entraînement l'ont
préparé à ce genre de situation une note
d'espoir vient remonter le moral de son
commando un avion américain passe dans
le ciel et magnum parvient à entrer en
contact avec lui et lui signaler sa
position
ce sera le seul et unique contact de la
patrouille avec des forces ennemies mais
une vague de froid s'abat sur toute la
région
un homme est frappée d'hypothermie tout
en se cachant à chaque apparition d'une
patrouille irakienne
dss perd un temps précieux à ranimer les
trois hommes hors de combat et les
irakiens les recherches très activement
finalement ils sont encore une fois
repéré le sergent mcnabb n'a plus
d'options devant lui on est sorti des
blancs pour compte et on s'est assis par
terre pour ce qu'on appelle entre nous
un parlement chinois
quand il s'agit simplement de faire le
point d'examiner les différents aspects
de la situation et de parvenir à une
conclusion pratique sur ce qu'il
convient de faire sur le point de se
muer en dernière analyse c'est le chef
de patrouille qui synthétise les
différentes options et prend la décision
la situation était la suivante
d'un côté il y avait le froid qui
risquait de nous tuer caron souffraient
tous plus ou moins d'hypothermie et d'un
autre côté il y avait les demis qui nous
tuerait toute aussi certainement et les
forces ennemies étaient bien plus
nombreuses que ce à quoi on s'attendait
je décidé d'intercepter et de voler un
véhicule sur la piste en tôle ondulée
qui se trouvait à quelques kilomètres de
notre position avant d'établir un
barrage nous avons établi un poste
d'observation non loin de là histoire de
voir quel véhicule passerai sur 7 comme
il fallait s'y attendre en a c'était
surtout des pick-up mazda des land
cruiser toyota des camions légers
finalement avec un de mes gars qui
s'appelait bob on
abandonner nos armes et on s'est posté
au bord de la route en essayant de se
faire passer pour des soldats irakiens
blessés
deux autres membres du commando étaient
en planque prêt à passer à l'action
venant de l'ouest des phares ont éclairé
la nuit on a fait de grands signes et le
véhicule s'est arrêté
les phares nous aveugler mes hommes sont
sortir nos points pour maîtriser le
chauffeur et c'est alors qu'on a pu
admirer une entreprise c'était un taxi
un taxi jaune un taxi new yorkais des
années 50 avec de superbes chrome aidez
le à flancs blancs
il semblait sorti tout droit d'un vieux
film c'était mieux que rien mais avec ça
on était condamné à rester sur la piste
pas question de faire du tout terrain
avec un engin pareil mais de toute façon
disposer de carterie des panthères j'ai
pris le volant tandis qu'un autre membre
de la patrouille
tim lane se chargeait de vérifier à la
boussole qu'on allait bien vers l'ouest
nous sommes parvenus à un carrefour une
piste à l'est vers l'ouest
on l'a empruntée et au fil des
kilomètres la circulation était de plus
en plus dense celui finalement on s'est
trouvé pris dans de véritables
encombrement à 100 km de la frontière
syrienne
là nous sommes tombés sur un barrage et
il a fallu passer à l'attaqué
essentiellement il s'agissait l'utiliser
à blain l'effet de surprise de donner
toute notre puissance de feu de s'enfuir
au plus vite en profitant de la
confusion ambiante
ça a très bien marché mais on se
trouvait maintenant dans une zone où la
densité de la population était très
forte
tout près du fleuve euphrate et c'était
impossible de passer inaperçu bien
longtemps il fallait absolument franchir
la frontière cette nuit là on a donc
poursuivi notre route vers l'ouest nous
avons eu un nouveau contact avec une
petite unité à kiel équipés d'armes
légères et ce après un bref échange de
feu on s'est dégagée centre de mal et on
est parvenu en vue de la frontière
c'était comme dans le film rencontre du
troisième type
du côté irakien un couvre-feu absolue et
du côté syrien
tout était illuminée hélas on est tombé
sur une ligne de fortin armée de
puissantes mitrailleuses de baisser
avant puis leur infanterie a commencé à
nous canarder dans la nuit la seule
solution consistait à aller vers le nord
quand j'ai essayé de traverser une
importante zone de concentration de
cannes on a réussi à passer à bestron et
on s'est retrouvé sur une ville de
l'euphrate a exactement 10 km de la
frontière
à cet instant il s'agissait avant tout
de retrouver notre sang-froid de remplir
nos cours d'eau fraîche et d'évaluer la
situation autour de nous c'était le
chaos
les soldats irakiens lancé à notre
poursuite courait dans tous les sens et
se tirer sans doute les uns sur les
autres dans le ciel les avions alliés
poursuivent et leur sarabande et l'adc a
tonné un peu partout il fallait profiter
de cette confusion pour reprendre notre
marche vers l'ouest
lentement et avec les précautions si la
patrouille s'est donc remise en marche
mais on s'est trouvé pris parmi les
échelons arrière d'un bataillon qui
stationnaient dans le secteur il
disposait d'une structure de
commandement solides avec des liaisons
radio multiples et de nombreux véhicules
qui patrouillaient sur des sentiers
aménagés
le combat a pris la forme d'une partie
de cache cache avec blain d'accrochages
sporadiques qui ont duré de onze heures
du soir jusqu'aux premières heures de la
matinée un de mes hommes a été tué cette
nuit là je ne sais plus très bien quelle
heure il était mais je l' ai vu qui
venait me rejoint ville avait reçu une
balle dans la tête
mais malgré tout il avait pu arriver
jusqu'à moi il a poussé un râle et il
est mort c'était bien au moins il est
mort rapidement le restant du commando
étaient éparpillés dans tous les sens il
n'était plus possible de se regrouper
autour de nous c'était le chaos nous
tiraient dessus on leur tire dessus ils
sont fusillés les uns les autres
sakri de partout des projecteurs balayé
leur terrain la confusion était la plus
totale
au gardien général ans s'interroge sur
le sort du commando bravo 2 0 après cet
accrochage
ça a été chacun pour soi le sergent
mcnabb est parvenu à moins de 5 km de la
frontière syrienne et de la liberté mais
là comme quatre des cinq survivants de
ce commando de huit sas il a été capturé
et emmené à bagdad tandis que la ville
été pilonné par l'aviation alliée ces
prisonniers de guerre portant l'uniforme
au moment de leur capture ont été
torturées par un ennemi sans odeur nous
avaient déshabillé et on était en
permanence enchaîné avec un bandeau sur
les yeux pour nous aveugler ils nous ont
frappés avec des planches de bois et ils
nous ont flageller j'avais une blessure
ouverte à la jambe
ils ont chauffé à blanc une cuillère et
l'on côté sur ma blessure a tout sous
les coups plusieurs mots l'air du côté
gauche de mâchoires se sont brisées
l'interrogateur a dit qu'il allait
appeler un dentiste aux années c'était
un vrai gentil il avait travaillé à
londres pendant neuf ans il est venu et
il m'a arraché les chicots avec des
pinces il nous est interrogé sans
relâche quand y en avait fini avec un
s'était aussitôt autour du suivant dans
les cellules les gardes venait
régulièrement des tabacs ses attentes
quel moment pour les empêche de dormir
il entrait sur laon et en gesticulant
nous ordonnait de nous lever ce qui est
fait est évidemment impossible sur le
plan physique on était tous brisé ont pu
et même quand on essayait de se
redresser il nous frapper et il nous
donnait des coups de pied des coups de
matraque les gardiens allait ainsi d'une
cellule à l'autre ce qui était assez
effrayant car on les entendait jouer
dira on savait que ça allait être notre
tour
cela a duré six jours j'ai été ramené au
centre d'interrogatoire nous savons que
vous commandez ces saboteurs donc il dit
et plusieurs d'entre eux sont à
l'hôpital
ils ont besoin de soins médicaux si vous
refusez de parler on va les laisser
mourir ainsi que votre accomplissent qui
sont prisonniers dans les cellules d'à
côté continued
j'ai continué à maintenir la première
version à savoir que nous étions un
commando a filtré derrière leur ligne
pour récupérer un équipages d'avions a
battu zoug
ce n'était pas un acte de bravoure au
nom de la reine est de l'angleterre
ce genre d'attitude n'existe pas dans la
réalité d'un bon en fait je voulais me
donner du temps pour analyser la
situation à la lumière de la raison pure
ce qu'on est physiquement incapable de
faire mal semaines d'interrogatoires
musclées on m'a alors ramené dans sa
cellule est battu intel encore et encore
stan mon compagnon de misère a fait une
hépatite tintin c'est moi aussi après on
vivait dans le froid au milieu de nos
excréments
alors ils ont cessé de nous tabasser
mais les deux autres avaient toujours
droit à des tabassages en règle
finalement j'ai pu mettre au point une
autre histoire
le raconter d'une part leur menace
paraissait trop réelle pour que je les
ignore
d'autre part il y avait une petite
chance qu'il gobe la salade que je
venais d'inventer il n'était pas
question de leur avouer qu'on était un
commando ss
il nous aurait exécuté sur le champ je
leur ai donc dit qu'on a partenaires
patru d'observation de l'infanterie
britannique et cela leur a paru
vraisemblable parmi eux il y avait
quelques officiers formés à l'académie
militaire de kimberley entre de londres
ces officiers savait que l'organisation
humanitaire britannique comporter de
telle unité attachée à chaque régiment
et ça a marché
interrogés à leur tour les autres
prisonniers ont confirmé mais dire et on
s'en est tirée la devise des sas et qui
ose gagne le mensonge du sergent mcnabb
a marché et les irakiens ont cessé de
torture et les rescapés de ce commando
quelques jours plus tard l'assaut
terrestre était donné avec le succès que
l'on sait sous l'égide de la croix rouge
des centaines de milliers de prisonniers
irakiens ont alors été échangés contre
une dizaine de prisonniers alliés
le sergent mcnabb et ces trois hommes
ont retrouvé le dernier survivant du
commando qui avait réussi à passer la
frontière syrienne
puis les corps des trois hommes tombés
au combat fut restitué rapatriés en
angleterre où il repose désormais dans
le cimetière réservé aux sas morts pour
la patrie
leur épopée malheureuse est venue
enrichir la légende de ces soldats
d'élite
leur sacrifice ne sera pas oublié
ans
oh
en